fear of missing out is an anxiety of
losing what we never even had and could
hence be described as an insane mental
defect however it is common real and can
make us feel deep regret for something
that hasn't actually happened
[Music]
fomo is an animal that shies away from
strangers and larger groups but loves to
hide within intimate social
relationships
it can attack your ego when a close
friend is getting ahead it tears you
down when others are having a good time
and you aren't invited
it beats you up if your rival gets what
ought to be yours and if you are love
sick and can't fall asleep it's your
fomo that will give you the worst
nightmares
fomo's full destructive force can be
observed in Tom and Jeff two friends who
decided to invest their savings into
Bitcoin back in 2012.
over the next few years the price of
Bitcoin went up a lot and the two began
to believe that they were brilliant
investors and that their bed was the
smartest move in their young lives
but they also became increasingly
concerned that something might happen to
that precious stake and this new
identity of theirs Tom experienced fear
of loss
then one day the price of Bitcoin
suddenly started falling and then
dropped dramatically
Tom's fear of loss became too strong and
he decided to sell half of his coins
Jeff a religious believer didn't sell
after he cashed out Tom felt relieved
even though his remaining Bitcoin
investment kept falling further
we see this happening Tom because while
he might still lose money he wants to
protect what has become even more
precious to him his identity of being
that brilliant investor but then our
story takes a dark twist
a short while later the price of Bitcoin
first stabilized and then kept Rising
faster and faster
but Tom who still held plenty of coins
wasn't happy no while he lay in bed at
night his fomo crapped out of hiding and
painted a terrifying future
Tom began to believe that he had made a
massive mistake that would leave him a
poor fool while his friend would be the
millionaire they both dreamed of
becoming
oh
and so even though he's still owned a
significant amount of Bitcoin he now
hoped for a total crash in its value and
the absolute failure of cryptocurrencies
so what's going on here
the fomo attacks Tom because Jeff is his
friend same age same tribe someone just
like him the difference is that while
Jeff is a brilliant investor Tom is an
idiot
and because Tom knows he could have
achieved Jeff's success and doesn't want
to live with that idea for the rest of
his life he hopes they'll both fail
miserably
research on fomo suggests there are no
gender differences higher fomo scores
are associated with younger age It's
associated with people who are neurotic
and those who are lonely experience it
more often
but which fear is stronger the fear of
losing what is ours or our fear of
missing out or rather even essentially
the same thing
please share your thoughts in the
comments below or tell us your own
experiences with feelings of anxiety
fear or fomo
[Music]
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com